foreign
what kind of cars do you drive in LA and
why well to be a minimalist you have to
have a Lamborghini so um
oh man yeah Mariah and I we have a 2016
RAV4
it's a Toyota yeah
um yeah I mean yeah I'm afraid the
answers aren't going to be very sexy for
you yeah and the reason they're not sexy
is it's it's rather practical I own a
Toyota as well not sponsored oh there
you go
um
the sexy answer is like I don't own a
car and I walk everywhere you have an
electric car uh yeah I live in Ojai so I
have to have a car
um but even when I lived here I owned a
car and I walked most of the time but
for practical reasons minimalism isn't
about
issuing all possessions right we aren't
ascetics we're not monks I don't want to
get rid of the things that add value to
my life although here's what I'll tell
you I will often remove something from
my life that I perceive that adds value
just to see whether or not it really
does add value and so it's really a
helpful exercise to get rid of home
internet to get rid of your TV to get
rid of your favorite shirt to get rid of
those shoes that you really like but you
never wear
[Music]
those are what I call aspirational
purchases by the way it's like I'll I'll
be the type of person who wears those
orange pumps
[Laughter]
and
we do that we get rid of those things
temporarily to see okay
because my life fine without it and
sometimes my life is even better without
it right my life has improved by
subtracting the thing that was actually
getting in the way now that said I own
stuff I'm not against stuff I don't
renounce stuff either and so if I had a
problem I know the woman earlier had a
problem with Robin had a problem with
Mary's poem the only problem I have with
the poem there is it feels like a
renunciation of things
and I don't want to renounce things
because soon as you renounce something
you're forever tethering yourself to it
and so I'm not saying that stuff is bad
that owning a certain number of things
is the right number
because there is no right or wrong here
the question is what serves me and what
serves you
and the tricky part is what serves you
right now
may not serve you a year from now and so
it's this constant Quest I wish there
was a list I wish I could just pick up
this piece of paper say guess what we
figured out the 100 things you should
own
and they're all for sale in the lobby
[Laughter]
but the money isn't first and so here we
are
and we've recognized that the things
that we own end up owning us if we have
to have them
or if we refuse to have them that's
another way of being owned by your
things
you know it's it's yeah it's interesting
so um I'm assuming this is your friend's
like first time ever hearing anything
from the minimalist is that
no this is my second time oh okay I just
I just liked what you said about people
being in La we're from LA and we
sometimes have to feel like we have to
be more LA because the somebody a
transplant that came here is more La
than us
[Music]
like I'm not like families
[Music]
that's great that's awesome
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100 advertisement free